[Music]
foreign
the happiness you pay for can be found
everywhere
[Music]
cheat fate then you'll be lucky
don't ask a blind man about the Sun
you can't pour water from a Leaky Barrel
[Music]
gypsy is not necessary to be of gypsy
origin the main thing is that your soul
sings
[Music]
don't let the tamed lioness tell you how
to live
[Music]
the stone is strong but the Gypsy Heart
is stronger
must put grain in the ground before he
can Harvest
here in the eye is a wound in the heart
after failure comes luck after bad luck
comes happiness
children will tell you what they do men
what they think
and older people what they have seen and
heard
he who makes a mistake gains his mind
the one who voluntarily gives you a
finger will give you the whole hand
better to be the head of a mouse than
the tale of a lion
[Music]
the world is a ladder where some go up
and others go down
winter will ask what we did all summer
[Music]
without wood a fire goes out
it is easier to milk a cow that is
standing still
[Music]
a dog that digs deeper finds bones
you can count the apples on a tree but
you can't count the trees from one apple
there are Masters over the Earth there
is no master over the Sun
don't eat onions and think your breath
won't smell
[Music]
the greedy man dreams of gold the Hungry
Man of bread
[Music]
a woman is a gypsy who lives by her own
rules
bad people don't sing
[Music]
wherever you go go with all your heart
men are like fish the great ones Devour
the small ones
[Music]
gypsies are happy wherever they are they
are nomads in a World's childhood
foreign
there is no better life than that of a
gypsy
[Music]
the woman's scolds the dog barks
the beard of a goat is long but she is
not a goat
the gray horse is the most enduring
the sky is a bird water is a fish the
road is a horse luck is a gypsy
[Music]
A Worn shirt will do for a rag
there is no better path than language
first chew a thought with your mind then
speak
we are all Wanderers on this Earth our
hearts are full of wonder and our souls
are deep with dreams
not all girls are made of sugar and
spice some girls are made of Adventure
dark chocolate whiskey intelligence and
cuss words
stay where there are songs
when the sea turned to Honey the poor
man lost his spoon
he who is late must gnaw the bones
a wise lawyer never goes to law himself
[Music]
even the white lily casts a shadow
Father's Day is the sequel to Mother's
Day
[Music]
if we can believe that success is
possible
success becomes possible
the patient Thief is as a tree whose
Roots Run Deep as he waits for the sweet
fruit to grow
[Music]
may your clothes wear out but may you
live on in good health and happiness
[Music]
the buyer needs a hundred eyes the horse
thief not one
there is a lot of water in the sea but
it is salty
friendship is a Furrow in the sand
[Music]
even the wolf gets devoured but it
remains a wolf
[Music]
Pig asks for oranges but was given
potatoes
Whoever has cold blood is not a gypsy
[Music]
for a bad husband a wife is a pair of
handcuffs and children are shackles
[Music]
by a scarf with Envy
a girl's honor is more precious than
money
fear not a shooting star but an evil
wife
a girl is a rose a woman is a daisy
thank you
in a strange Camp all brides are good
honey would be sweeter if bees didn't
sting
cunning without mind is worth half a
penny
[Music]
call yourself stay human
you don't need a comb if you have no
hair
[Music]
a blunt needle cannot mend a scarf
oh
the groom has good words the husband bad
the capricious bride is the devil's
groom
fate is fate but will is Will
[Music]
to survive you must be smarter than
others
[Music]
as they sing so they dance
do not spit in cabbage soup if there is
no meat you will anger God
[Music]
you can't make a mare out of a wolf
if the family is friends they don't
grieve about anything
[Music]
there is no horse with six legs
a girl has honor a woman has loyalty
a young wife is an enemy to an old
husband
if you live with an evil wife you will
be angry
never eat at the table of a priest
to abort wife her husband is boring
to give a girl for an old man is to
start trouble
foreign